Ja er hat es tatsächlich geschafft es ist aktuell die größte rakete der welt gebaut von spacex dem raumfahrtunternehmen von ihnen
Maske jetzt startet sie ins all mit
Seinem tesla roadster als test fach das ist wirklich groß alle tests sind absolviert heute abend soll es in den weltraum
Gehen was jetzt noch schief gehen kann und warum dieser staat bahnbrechend ist jetzt in den edlen mars chroniken bei klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Ich glaube zu keinem thema haben mich so viele kommentare und whatsapp nachrichten erreicht alle wollen alle news zur falcon heavy
heute abend soll sie starten eine weltpremiere
Fast 45 jahre nach dem letzten flug der bisher heute noch. Größten rakete der menschheit der saturn 5
Startet ein neues monstrum eine neue ära der raumfahrt beginnt keine rakete kann so vielen nutzlast transportieren
Je nach ort kann sie bis zu
63,8 tonnen last in den weltraum bringen das ist immens bei der falken ein sind ist
22,8 also nur ein drittel dabei ist die falcon heavy
eigentlich eine umgebaute felgen oder anders gesagt die erste stufe der falcon heavy ist eine umgebaute
Erste stufe der falken ein wie bei der felgen sind neun merlin 1d
triebwerke an bord die jeweils in diesem fall 8 145 kilo newton start schub leisten dazu kommen 2 booster mit denselben
spezifikationen zusammen leisten sie unglaubliche
22,8 minuten
Durch die hohe zahl an triebwerken können sogar welche ausfallen so dass die mission dann nicht mehr
Gefährdet wäre die zweite stufe dagegen entspricht einer etwas verlängertem zweiten stufe der verein mit einem umgebauten berlin einst im triebwerk mit
617 kilonewton schub es kam insgesamt
353 sekunden gezündet werden der start erfolgt an einem historischen ort von der apollo
startrampe launchpad 9 30 h in cape kennedy von hier aus starteten alle apollo flüge inklusive
Der legendären apollo 11 nur die apollo 10 die mond umrundung die ist nichts von dieser
Rampe gestarteten musk spacex hat die startrampe für 20 jahre von der nasa geleast und die rakete
fliegt eine vollkommen irrsinnige lasst das muss man schon sagen den weltraum der tesla roadster familien maske höher gehört zur ersten generation
Rot sah wurde 2009 produziert seitdem wurde er von mas gefahren und jetzt wird es eine strecke zurücklegen
Dieses auto die noch nie ein privatauto zurücklegt hat das ist wirklich ziemlich
Absolut verrückt aber noch verrückter ist das was sie denn maskin das auto gepackt hat an bord wird
Zusammen eine puppe seien benannt nach einem song von david bowie aus dem album the rise and fall of ziggy stardust
And the spiders from mars dazu muss man wissen dass david bowie auch in einem
Weltraum kostüm als ziggy stardust auftrat er ist jetzt quasi
als samen an bord der falcon heavy
Dass es wirklich der absolute wahnsinn und eine ehre finde ich ja eine tolle geste die audio anlage
wird den song space oddity von david bowie spielen und dem handschuhfach ist eine ausgabe von per anhalter durch die galaxis
von douglas adams und ein handtuch mit der aufschrift keine
parallelen zu der seltsamen fracht ich liebe den gedanken an ein auto das wahrscheinlich endlos durch das
weltall driftet und in ein paar millionen jahren vielleicht von einer außerirdischen
spezies entdeckt wird wenn die rakete nicht beim start explodiert das meint er denn das kann ja tatsächlich
schief gehen der roadster wird übrigens sind eine umlaufbahn
Um die sonne einschwenken und dann weiter zum mars fliegen ihnen maske anspielung auf seine pläne den mars ball zu besiedeln
Darüber gibt es sicher bald mehr
Infos von ihm wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hier bei
Whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit
Genau vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken mit 1000 raketen zum mars da geht es um ihnen
us-pläne für die besiedlung des mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt